what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to top five Tuesday a
weekly series where we count down the
top 5 characters teams and concepts from
across the comic book industry and this
week were counting down my top 5
favorite versions of the flash number 5
max mercury first appearing in 1940 with
national comics number 5 is part of the
superhero Renaissance of the Golden Age
max mercury was ambiguous at best except
to say that he had SuperSpeed
however under mark Wade's legendary
wally west run max Mercury's background
was fully fleshed out in the 1995 story
terminal velocity originally hailing
from the 1830s as a member of the u.s.
cavalry max mercury was blessed by a
local shaman after his tribe was wiped
out
granny max the ability to move its
superhuman speeds from that point
forward he was simply referred to as the
wind runner constantly trying to make
contact and enter the Speed Force the
source of energy and afterlife for all
the speedsters max Mercury's attempts
initially sent him into the future each
time he tried to enter the Speed Force
his first trip set him to the 1890s
where he became the hero with whirlwind
and his second attempt landed him in the
1930s in the 1940s where he served as a
teacher for the Golden Age flash Jay
Garrick meaning that within the comic
books matched mercury was the first
flash while he's not able to run as fast
as everyone else he is able to perform
acrobatic feats on a level greater than
the other members of the flash family
number 4 eobard thawne while he's not
technically a member of the flash family
I can't think of anybody who would make
any kind of a list about the flash and
not include eobard thawne none better
under his alias professor zoom eobard
first appearances in the flash comics
established him as having an obsession
with Barry Allen duplicating the
experiment that gave Barry his powers
and even going so far as having his face
transform to look like the iconic hero
eobard thawne's journey into the past
left his mind in shambles discovering a
museum and learning that he was destined
to become the reverse-flash the
arch-nemesis of Barry Allen
Thawne lost his mind and in turn stepped
into the world that he was destined for
while various stories would depict him
going against heroes like Wally West and
the rest of the flash family in the 2009
story flash rebirth Geoff Johns had
retcon much of eobard thawne's history
keeping his origin intact Johnson
established that eobard thawne murdered
Barry Allen's mother Nora Allen and
intentionally positioned the chemicals
in a way that would guarantee Barry's
transformation into the flash
effectively creating a circular paradox
number three Barry Allen as the Silver
Age flash Barry Allen was instrumental
in helping DC to capitalize on the
resurgence of superhero popularity
following the end of World War two first
appearing in DC showcase issue number
four which served as an anthology series
exposing new readers to characters in
order to test their popularity Barry
Allen was shown to have gained his
powers too due to being exposed to
chemicals during a lightning storm
discovering that he could move with
incredible speed Barry would go on to
christen himself as the flash arguably
considered the most powerful version of
the flash to date Barry Allen's history
has had him involved in some of DC's
most iconic events including the
formation of the Justice League in 1960
the advent of the comic book multiverse
in the flash of two worlds story in 1961
and the sacrificial lamb with the crisis
on Infinite Earths in 1985 while his
character would remain absent from DC's
landscape for almost 20 years
- occasional appearances in 2009 Barry
Allen made his return with flash rebirth
but also served as a catalyst for the
2011 flashpoint event which would allow
DC to consolidate all of their
characters and teams canceled low
selling titles and reboot everything
else - Batman and the Green Lantern with
a new 52 number - Wally West considered
by many to be the best version of the
flash this sentiment seems to be due
more to the fact that many readers grew
up with Wally West rather than the idea
that Wally is inherently better than
Barry while opinions vary regarding his
popularity wally west was initially
introduced in 1959 as a nephew of
Barry's love interest iris West
gaining his powers in the exact same
experiment that gave Barry his powers
Wally West became Kid Flash and his
journey to learn the nature of his
powers was fast-tracked due to Barry
functioning as his mentor following the
crisis on Infinite Earths event in 1985
and the death of Barry Allen Wally West
took over the signature role and was
initially written by Mike Barron who
depicted him as having won the lottery
but whose life was constantly
overshadowed by the memory of Barry
Allen however
automark Wade in 1992 Wally West was cut
loose from
ties that held him to Barry and in turn
became one of the most powerful versions
of the flash even possessing powers that
Barry didn't including the ability to
lend all or a portion of his SuperSpeed
to others
number one Jay Garrick maybe I'm a
sucker for the originals but to me Jay
Garrick will always be the best flash
while he is slower than Barry Allen and
his publication history isn't filled
with the same achievements my reason for
selecting Jay Garrick is my favorite
version of the flash is because he's the
guy who started it all
initially appearing in flash Comics
number one in 1940 Jay Garrick was DC's
attempt to capitalize on the success of
Superman and it gained his powers by
falling asleep while inhaling deuterium
a chemical used in atomic weaponry
waking up several weeks later with the
power of SuperSpeed Jay Garrick's
popularity during the 1940s going into
the 1950s set the stage for the
popularity of Barry Allen and the Silver
Age of comics furthermore introducing a
character who could move at a speed
similar to Superman albeit without
flight was what solidified Jay Garrick
as a popular character during the Golden
Age and while his return to the DC
landscape during flash of two worlds
following his cancellation after World
War two would depict him playing second
fiddle to Barry in the end had it not
been for Jay Garrick the flash family as
exists now would not likely be as
popular as it is assuming that it would
exist at all with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end and
post a comment below letting me know who
your favorite version of the flash is
and I will catch you guys on it peace